nous nous sommes rencontrés pour la
première fois à votre demande de 27
juillet dernier et je vous avais fait
part de ma grande préoccupation sur la
situation sociale de la rentrée de
septembre et je vous avais proposé une
revalorisation significative du SMIC
mais surtout l'organisation d'une grande
conférence salariale pour anticiper les
difficultés financières prévisibles de
l'immense majorité de nos concitoyens
la vie répondu que tel ne serait pas
votre choix
privilégiant la seule solution des
accords de branche
aujourd'hui le désordre s'installe la
colère gronde et les premières victimes
sont les salariés obligés de prendre
leur voiture la crise des carburants que
traverse notre pays et le premier étage
d'une crise sociale généralisée qui est
sur son pas de tir
les inégalités se creusent et ce n'est
qu'un début faire preuve d'autoritarisme
en réquisitionnant les salariés sans
responsabiliser les employeurs ne
permettra pas de revenir à une paix
sociale à laquelle nous aspirons aucune
prime même Macron limité dans le temps
et dans l'espace ne remplacera une
revalorisation durable des salaires vous
n’anticipez plus vous ne faites plus que
pallier et mal par des rustines
extrêmement coûteuses pour la solidarité
nationale que vous convoquez pour mieux
exonérer les plus aisés de nos
concitoyens les pompes à essence
s'assèchent le pouvoir d'achat est
siphonné par l'inflation mais les
dividendes eux continuent à ruisseler
madame la Première ministre cette
situation est absurde certaines
entreprises peuvent tripler leur
bénéfices profitant de la crise actuelle
mais sans augmenter leurs salariés mais
sans contribuer à l'effort national ma
question est donc simple face à cette
aberration allez-vous choisir le camp de
la résignation ou le camp du combat pour
la justice sociale
pour vous répondre
[Musique]